>>Brady Forrest: Hi, I'm Brady Forrest.
[ Applause ]
Mike, you have to hit "next slide." There
we go.
And welcome to Ignite! This is our third year
here and, wow, we are bigger than ever. This
room holds 800 people and we were able to
get beer. So if you would like a drink, feel
free to line up. Please do it rather quietly
because geeks like to share. They like to
share their ideas, and that's what we are
going to be doing here at Ignite today.
However, everybody shares a little more freely
when they know that the audience has been
pacified, when they know that the audience
is a little more receptive. And geeks like
beer so we figured that's the best way to
get you into the mood for the nine next talks
that are coming up.
Who here has been to Ignite before?
All right. Who here has been to Ignite at
I/O before?
All right. Well, for those of you who have
never been here before or been to Ignite before,
Ignite is a geek event. We'll have a series
of five-minute talks. Each speaker gets 20
slides, 15 seconds per slide. They have no
control over their slides. Once their slides
start, off they go. So, wisely, they all said
no to beer.
They are each going to have one afterwards.
If they come up to the bar, please let them
jump ahead of you.
We have nine awesome talks tonight. We've
got the head of security and resource management
from Burning Man. We have got Matt Cutts from
the Google spam team.
And some administrata. If you have feedback
about this session, if you want an even bigger
room next year, please vote on that on Pamela
Fox's feedback system.
Without further ado, I would like to welcome
my roommate from Boston back in the '90s.
He is now at Twitter, and he is going to instruct
all of our speakers on how to use a microphone.
Please welcome John Adams.
[ Applause ]
>>John Adams: Thank you, Brady. Thank you
very much. All right. Speak into the mic.
This thing is a microphone. Everyone has one.
Everyone has been to a conference. Everyone
has used one before. But a lot of people don't
know how to use them.
I want to do is give you a quick history lesson
on how we got to where we are today, how we
ended up with this thing in our hand and where
it goes.
And it all started back in the day with three
guys. We have Whetstone, Berliner and Hughes.
Whetstone invented this thing called the all-mechanical
vibration stethoscope. It was two pieces of
metal he used to amplify small sounds.
Now, he did a lot of work on telegraph, on
technology and security and things like that.
He invented the Playfair Cipher.
One of the things that Hughes did is Hughes
invented this thing called a carbon granular
microphone. This is a brief diagram of it.
We still use this design today in most microphones.
And the funny thing about it is, it is so
simple but it is really bad. The problem with
that is that as an omni-directional move.
This is a Western Electric Microphone for
the 1920s. This microphone pretty much paved
the way for the talkies for the early movies
that actually had audio to go with them. The
problem is they were big, ugly. They sat on
a desk, and they were really hard to work
with.
And by omni-directional, I mean it listens
to everything.
This microphone is a uni-directional microphone.
If I move it over here, you don't hear me.
If I put it in front of me, you don't hear
me either. It listens to everything it can
get its hands on in the room.
A lot of work was done in the 1930s to improve
the pickup pattern of microphones.
This is the pickup pattern of Henry Olson's
microphone. He worked for RCA. This is a Figure
8 microphone. It picks up in the front and
little bit in the back. This is really not
the best microphone you can have because it
has no rejection. This is a cardiod microphone.
It looks like a heart. Olson refined his microphone
by taking two microphones and putting them
back to back and subtracting one from the
other and using super position of waves was
able to delete the interference that came
out of the back of the microphone and only
give you what was in front of it. And that's
the microphone I'm holding today, is a cardiod.
This is another famous microphone, 1937 Olson's
77A microphone. You may have seen this on
"The David Letterman Show." This microphone
is very popular. It was a ribbon microphone.
It really refined and gave you better audio
quality.
And this is another famous microphone for
the 1940s. This is the Shure 55A. You will
still see this if you go see a swing band
in any local night club here in San Francisco.
It is the favorite of the Kruners. It is a
really pretty microphone, and it has great,
great sound, legendary.
In the 1960s, a lot of research went into
building the electric microphone. The electric
microphone can be seen in everything from
telephones to answering machines. About a
billion of these microphones were produced.
They are really amazing little things. And
they are based on the original carbon design.
In 1966, something amazing happen. The Shure
Brothers released a microphone called the
Shure SM58. This is actual a beta 52 that
I'm using, it looks like. This microphone
is absolutely legendary. You will see this
in every nightclub and every conference everywhere.
The one thing about all this is when you finally
get one of these in your hands don't be shy.
People get frequently mic shy. I'm up here
on stage. It is hard to be on stage, I will
give you that. The thing is you can't be shy
when you have a microphone in your hand. It
goes right in the mouth. It goes right in
your mouth right here. So the thing is, voices
come from your head. They don't come from
your chest. They come from your head.
Don't be this guy. The microphone does not
sit in the stand down below. You have to have
the microphone in your mouth. It is kind of
scary. Not too much though. If you put it
too much in your mouth, you sound terrible.
The big thing about microphones is the distance
between you and the microphone makes a huge
difference. If I pull back even 4 inches,
the sound completely changes. That's the thing.
That distance controls everything: The size
of your voice, the volume of your voice and
the way microphone listens to you.
Another very interesting thing about microphones,
if you get the microphone too close, you get
this thing called a proximity effect. The
proximity effect is a big boost around 400
hertz. It is a big boost in the volume and
the base of your voice, the big, low mid section.
And sometimes that's good. If you are a rapper,
you want that.
But the thing is you get it too close, you
might be eating the microphone. Eating the
microphone is not good either. The microphone
does not go in your mouth. It does not go
on your mouth. It goes in front of your mouth.
Do not eat the microphone.
All right. This is -- so overall gain, if
the microphone is too loud, what you actually
do with your voice is you push the capsule
of the microphone down to the back of the
mic. When you do that, the microphone goes
into overload and it clips and the sound guy
gets very mad. As a sound guy myself, I have
seen this happen before.
Another interesting problem is feedback. If
the microphone can pick up the speakers that
are around here -- up on stage, I have a bunch
of these tiny monitor speakers. If I was to
push this microphone into one of these speakers,
you would get a nice loud squeal and the sound
guy would probably kill me. You have to be
very careful and very conscious of feedback.
The real thing you want to do is keep that
mic straight on and you are going to get great
sound.
All you can do is put the mic in front of
you, even if it is on the stand and you will
get fantastic sound tonight. I hope that all
the ignite speakers tonight have learned something
from this. And we'll hopefully have great
sound during the performance. Thank you very
much.
[ Applause ]
>>Brady Forrest: And hopefully all the speakers
for tomorrow have also paid attention.
Our next speaker is the editor-in-chief of
IO9. She has been giving sci-fi-based Ignite
talks since 2007. Please welcome No. 6, aka
Annalee Newitz.
[ Applause ]
>>Annalee Newitz: I'm going to be talking
to you a little bit about how science fiction
represents the future of social media. And
I'm lucky because I guess I'm getting a little
extra time here.
And I think this is an interesting thing to
do if you are working with social media, if
you are developing it or using it because
it gives you a chance to kind of sit back
and think a little bit about what kind of
future you might be building with your technology.
And also it gives us a chance to kind of take
the temperature of the culture and, say, Well,
what are people's fantasies about the future
of social media and media that comes from
computer networks? What are our hopes and
our fears about it?
So I'm going to take you through about four
common stories that science fiction tells
us about the future of social media. The first
is one that's very popular in science fiction
literature and also among developers, which
is some kind of hive mind or artificial intelligence
will rise up out of our social networks and
out of our user-generated data. Even Larry
Page is a big fan of this idea and has said
he is enthusiastic and hoping that one day
Google Search will become an artificial intelligence.
The question is: Will this artificial intelligence
be smart or stupid?
Will it be like the AI in "Neuromancer" by
William Gibson, which is so smart it is able
to eventually be to leave the planet. Will
it be kind of a trickster like in Verner Vinge's
"Amazing Rainbow's End" or will it be just
as dumb as a shark as it is in a fantastic
short story by Maureen McCue.
There is also the story of the proverbial
privacy apocalypse that would be brought on
by social media invading every part of our
lives, surveilling us, turning the vessels
of our entertainment into our own -- into
a spy show.
Obviously, one of the key stories in this
genre is "1984" where people are watched by
their telescreens.
But there's also a number of other stories
that deal with this in a slightly different
way, which is, for example, in the 1960s Philip
K. Dick's novels including the short story
"Minority Report" as well as things like "Scanner
Darkly" where he imagines a future of ubiquitous
advertising and social media that not only
invades our lives but also invades our minds.
And I would conclude by talking about a book
that just came out in the U.S. called "The
Quantum Thief" by Hannu Rajaniemi. It has
been out for about a year in England. He suggests
in the future the way that we'll handle privacy
will be that our post-human selves will develop
organs that negotiate privacy each time we
meet with somebody. And so everything -- all
of our thoughts are saved to the Internet,
but we can decide who gets to remember those
thoughts and who gets to remember meeting
with us and seeing us.
Another fear about social media is that it
will lead to mind control, will jack our minds
into the networks and suddenly there will
be no difference between what corporations
want us to think and what we actually are
thinking.
And there is different ways this gets played
out. The matrix is a perfect example where
everyone's brains are being controlled by
a massive game-like simulation to keep us
pacified while we are being used by machines
as batteries so we are reduced to the lowest
common denominator.
There is another fantasy, of course, that
comes out in Neal Stephenson's classic novel
"Snow Crash" as well as Charlie's Stross'
terrific book, "Glasshouse" which both are
about how people catch viruses in their brains
from being plugged into media online.
And so, basically, your brain crashes or stops
behaving correctly.
And then, of course, there is the movie "They
Live," which is about how media is actually
secretly controlling us, telling us to obey
these aliens who have taken over the world.
This is a great screen shot from the film
when the characters finally see what's going
on.
The flip side of mind control is the idea
that social media will lead to instant social
revolution and that through using social media
the grassroots, journalists and reporters
and anyone reporting the news will be able
to continue doing their work even better.
A classic show in this vein is "Max Headroom"
from the 1980s where an intrepid reporter
uses television signals to broadcast ideas
that the corporations don't want us to hear.
This idea is elaborated also in the classic
comic book "Transmetropolitan" by Warren Ellis
which features a reporter who is telling the
truth about crime in the city and using underground
means and using social media.
Also, social media vigilantes like Anonymous
have used "V for Vendetta," the classic comic
book which actually isn't about social media,
as a symbol for their social media revolutions.
Another book that I would recommend if you
are interested in social media is "Feed" which
is about how bloggers are the only people
who are willing to report on the zombie apocalypse
and so all of the traditional reporters are
killed in the zombie apocalypse but the bloggers
survive.
I would say that our hopes and fears about
the future of social media are embodied by
the phrase from the movie "Serenity, You can't
Stop the Signal," which is the idea that revolutionary
ideas will get out. You can't stop that. But,
also, I think the fear is that you won't be
able to stop the signal that controls your
mind as well. So there's both a fear and hope
embodied in that phrase.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you, Annalee.
And I do want to second that recommendation,
"Feed" is a really fun book. And I'm a connoisseur
of the zombie genre. I know, and the sequel
is coming out soon.
Our next speaker has been speaking at O'Reilly
conferences for quite a while, usually talking
about the interference between body and technology.
He today is going to be talking about the
Open You project. Please welcome Kyle Machulis.
[ Applause ]
>>Kyle Machulis: Hey, what's up Ignite? Don't
answer that. I don't have that much time.
My name is Kyle Machulis, and this is your
brain but this is also your brain on bugs.
I'm looking to put the U back into code, even
though it didn't have an U in it already,
even maybe if you are British. I don't know.
Here's what I do. I do a lot of stuff, and
it involves game controllers and Abe Vigoda
and Kinect and everything else.
Basically, I reverse engineer video game hardware
because it is cheap and people can get to
it and they can use it for research and academia
and robots like you saw upstairs.
So I really, really like numbers obviously.
And now there is this new thing called The
Quantified Self Movement, which is all about
numbers about you. You can do all these things
like introspection and journaling and, basically,
making yourself a better person. But really
it means more hardware because hardware's
awesome. So there's consumer hardware which
there's things like EEGs and blood pressure
monitors and pedometers and sleep meters.
But the problem is with these, the business
model is that they upload their data back
to a walled garden so you can only access
it through there and you have to pay for it
and it really sucks.
And beyond that, there's medical hardware,
real honest to God medical hardware. This
is inside people at the moment and they can't
actually get the data out. Yeah, that's a
pacemaker and it talks wirelessly only to
the company that owns it. Freaky.
Yeah. So, I started this thing called the
Open You project. Open You is about reverse
engineering all of this stuff and handing
it back to the community and then doing really
interesting stuff with it, too, that's just
fun. For instance, there's the Golden Gate
Wall Project. Golden Gate Wall is all about
-- I'm skipping ahead of my own slides. I'm
actually going too fast. Awesome.
So here's some things that we actually do
in our projects. We've done libfitbit for
reverse engineering the Fitbit pedometer.
There is Emokit, which is for the emotive
EEG to get the raw waves out. These are available
in C, Python, SWIG. And then we put them all
together in projects like Golden Gate Wall,
which is all about doing rock climbing the
most computational way possible. We scan walls.
We take biometrics and trying to do automated
route generation.
So that really pisses off people.
[ Laughter ]
So what all this needs is a shared time base.
We need to be able to take all of these sensors,
write our own drivers for them and record
all of them into the same stream of data.
We are not the only people that are doing
this.
For instance, there is a company called Neurofocus.
They are actually over in Berkeley and they
do this for advertising. They put an EEG on
you and they show you ads they watch when
your brain reacts to the ad. So they can tell
actually tell whether you really like Tide
before you even know you like Tide.
But we -- the thing is, I mean, I like rock
climbing. I'm not really into advertising.
But most of the time, I'm sitting. I'm sitting,
and I'm programming. And I might as well just
be flipping off my pedometer at this point.
So what can I do about that? The problem is,
when I'm programming, I kind of go into this
hole. I will be like sitting there, and then
there is some code. It is eight hours later,
but it only feels like one or two. There is
a product, and it is awesome. But I kind of
miss myself at that point. So what can we
do about that?
That's why I created the Quantified Coder
Project. Quantified Coder is all about getting
us back into our coding because right now,
we're sitting there with IDEs but we aren't
really there anymore.
What do we do about that? We need to look
at what metrics can we take from the coding
environment? There is your chair that we can
put accelerometers on. There is IDE which
we can track. We can check the stroke force
of your keyboard. We can put EEGs on you.
We can put electromyographs on you. We will
get to that in a sec.
There is lots of information we can take.
We can start instrumenting your IDE because
obviously everyone is using Emacs, right?
[ Laughter ]
So there are other scriptable IDEs. Why would
you use them? You can actually add this to
the time base with the other sensors I mentioned
earlier.
So now we track things -- we track the sensors
on the programmer against their line of code.
What were your brain waves doing when you
wrote this line of code? What was your hand
doing and how tense was it when you wrote
this line of code? Did you get up? Your pedometer
can actually look at when you left your code.
And then we can see when going into a bug
review, Hey, you are feeling tired when you
wrote this code. You got up. You lost your
concentration when you wrote this code.
[ Laughter ]
More importantly, we can use machine learning.
We can use machine learning to say, Okay.
There was a bug here. How did you feel at
this time? Now, find all of the other places
that you felt the same way while writing this
code.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, we can get really crazy with this.
We can go to social coding projects like Google
code and Gethub and actually upload all of
our biometrics together to give a human picture
of a library or framework or something like
that so everyone can know how frustrated you
are when you use it.
So, anyways, that is the Quantified Coder
Project.
[ Applause ]
I'm looking for help. This is completely open
source. I need everyone's data, and I mean
all of you.
[ Applause ]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you very much, Kyle.
I apologize. I spoke with him before about
the Emacs propaganda, and I -- we had a -- Kyle,
not next time!
[Laughter]
All right. Our next speaker, is actually the
chief of emergency services for Burning Man.
I biffed his title earlier. And he's here
to talk about risk management at Burning Man
and other amusement parks and how it applies
to your lives. Please welcome Joseph Pred.
[Applause]
>>Joseph Pred: Burning Man, on the very off
chance you don't know about it, is the annual
fire arts festival that takes place in the
northern Nevada desert, and out there, we
seek to find the balance, the sweet spot,
between risk and reward and experience.
And this is the secret sauce, really: that
humans crave and seek intense and vibrant
experiences. So we allow that experience to
take place between a balance of safety and
risk choice.
And you say to yourself, "Well, I don't do
risk management. How does it really apply
to me?" Well, every time you cross the street,
you're engaging in risk management. Especially
if you're jaywalking, like these people are.
[Laughter]
And so -- and it shows up everywhere in your
life once you start looking for it.
And what wouldn't a risk management talk be
without a few disclaimers?
So common sense is not common.
So this doesn't apply to financial risk management
or any number of other risk categories.
And no one likes to be told no. It sacrifices
the experience. It lacks flexibility. It lacks
creativity. It denies the entire process of
learning your own boundaries.
And it doesn't really -- it's not really a
form of risk management. It's really bypassing
the entire process. It's confused, sometimes,
with risk management, but you're just eliminating
the experience.
And no one really likes that.
And we're also dealing with a society that's
got warning label overload.
[Laughter]
And everywhere you turn, there's warnings,
right? "Hot coffee may be hot." "May cause
drowsiness." "Sharp edges may be sharp."
And what that does is it sanitizes the experience
through the results of all these lawsuits,
and in my mind Disneyland personifies the
sanitized experience. Sure it's fun, but you've
got long lines, barricades, highly controlled
and engineered environments. Look but don't
touch.
The experience is dictated for you.
Burning Man is a bit of an alternative. Sure,
it's also engineered for safety, but it's
an open environment where risk can be taken
as a choice as part of the experience.
And people who come to Burning Man accept
risk as part of that experience. People come
back from the first time, especially, saying,
"My God, I just had the most amazing experience
of my life. I feel completely transformed
as a person." And the question that I often
ask myself is: How many people say that when
they return from Disneyland?
So know your own level of risk tolerance.
This is Philippe Petit crossing between the
twin towers on a wire. He certainly knows
what his level of risk tolerance is. So seek
to understand what your level of aversion
and tolerance is to risk. And this is a slogan
that's really popular in the extended Burning
Man community because if you accept risk,
then experience becomes the first priority,
not safety.
And what's -- if you -- really, if you make
safety a priority, then you lose the immediacy
of the experience.
This is my highly unscientific and subjective
chart.
You got shuffleboard down there. You got cave
diving up there. And what's at the origin
of danger and fun? In my opinion, it's boredom.
Own your own outcomes. If you're going to
play with fire, accept the fact that sooner
or later you're going to get burned, so take
and ask others to take responsibility for
their own choices and actions.
Extreme risks are the ones that you want to
eliminate. For example, this is Euchronia.
It's several hundred feet in diameter -- and
it's on fire, by the way -- and there's no
barricades.
This allows for an immediacy and an intimacy
with the piece that barricades would just
not allow.
This is the ladder to nowhere. It's 108 feet
tall, and no safety harnesses were provided.
So if you chose to engage in this experience
and climb this ladder to see what it felt
like to be that high up, you were free to
do so.
Or not.
And it's imperative that you communicate to
people that they're making choices about risk
and what they're -- they're engaging in. And
the more you can communicate that risk, the
more people are going to be free to explore
their own boundaries. The back of the Burning
Man tickets say "By attending this event,
you freely accept the risk of injury or death."
Because lawsuits are everywhere. You cannot
eliminate the risk of lawsuits.
Disneyland isn't immune. Burning Man isn't
immune. No business is immune.
The only way to be immune is to not be in
business at all.
So if you accept risk as part of the experience,
then mitigate the risks that you can while
focusing on the experience, and keep in mind
my favorite Voltaire quote: "Perfect is the
enemy of good enough."
Now, I know for some of you, risk is a little
bit too scary, so you can always, instead,
go home and sit on the Internet and look at
cute pictures of kittens and puppies.
Thanks.
[Applause]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you very much, Joseph.
Clear the way for him to get a beer.
He was too -- I don't know why he didn't say
it but he's got a book coming out in June
"Show Me How To Survive." If I was going to
read one survival book this year, it would
be his.
Our next speaker, you wouldn't know it from
looking at her, but she's actually shy, and
she's here somehow braving the world to come
up here and talk about it. Please welcome
ex-Googler Pamela Fox.
[Cheers and applause]
>>Pamela Fox: Okay. Hi, everyone. For the
last five years, up until a few months ago,
I worked at Google as
a developer advocate. My job was to give talks,
organize events, post in forums and basically
spend all day every day communicating with
developers. So hearing that, you'd probably
think I'm an incredibly outgoing and social
person. But I'm not. I'm shy. I'm really shy!
What does that mean? Well, for me, it means
I'm afraid of approaching people and talking
to people. Especially when it's me and a group
of strangers. Situations like that I'd much
rather be standing in the corner, pretending
to amuse myself with some farm animal themed
mobile app.
Now, ultimately it's because it's a -- I have
a fear of rejection. You know, as long as
I don't approach people, I don't have to worry
that they're going to ignore me or turn me
away. And I could not worry about it and just
live in a hole for the rest of my life, but
eventually holes get lonely and you need a
little of that human touch.
Quick survey time. How many of you guys consider
yourselves shy? Don't be shy. Raise your hands.
Okay. And how many of you want a little of
that human touch? Okay. Now, touch your neighbor.
Okay. Great.
[Laughter]
Okay. So you guys, you know, you kind of know
what I'm talking about, right?
Now, I've been shy for a long time and I've
also been wanting to not be shy for a long
time, so I've spent approximately my whole
lifetime developing work-arounds, and since
I think the world would be a better place
if we weren't all deathly afraid of each other,
I'm going to share some of my ideas with you
guys today.
So my main approach takes a couple of different
forms, but it basically boils down to this:
Since I'm afraid of approaching people, I
need to get other people to approach me, so
that means giving them a really good excuse
to talk to me. And I can do that a couple
different ways.
One way is to get myself in a group of leadership
-- position of leadership over a group of
people. It may be a group that already exists
or it may be a group I create myself, like
a club. And once you do that, the people can
approach you with group-related matters.
Like when I was class president in high school,
my classmates would talk to me about what
love songs we should play at prom. Now, once
you're in charge of that group, you can organize
events. Of course you have to get people to
actually show up at the events, but usually
if you're interested in something, somebody
else will be too. Except this one time when
I organized the viewing of Moulin Rouge. That
was just me.
[Laughter]
But stick with tech buzzwords, you'll be okay.
So maybe you think it's too much effort to
actually organize a club in order to get people
to talk to you. I understand. So a step down
from that is actually be a speaker. When you
deliver a talk to a group of people, like
I'm doing now, there will be a whole room
of people afterwards that know who you are
and, even better, who know what conversation
topics they can approach you with.
Speaking isn't easy. I still get sick right
before I go on stage, but it's worth it. When
I went to Sydney, Australia, moved there,
didn't know anyone, I gave two talks at the
local bar camp my first weekend there and
met 90% of my Ozzie friends. Find a topic
you're passionate about. Find a group of people.
Speak about it.
And when you do find an event to talk at,
try and talk early in the event, right? If
it's a multiday conference, speak on the first
day. If it's a one-day conference, speak before
lunch. You're giving people the most amount
of time that they can actually approach you
and talk to you about stuff in your talk.
Okay. So maybe you're not up for speaking,
but clearly you guys are about attending events
because you're all here today, and I applaud
you for that because it's really nerve-wracking
to show up at an event with thousands of people
you don't know, right? How does anyone approach
you in a sea of strangers? Well, they need
some conversation topic they know interests
both of you.
Ideally, we'd all walk around with augmented
reality Android apps that would visualize
auras of hash-tags around each other and auto-target
us to whoever has the most overlapping tags.
Doesn't exist yet. Maybe after tomorrow's
keynote it will. I don't know.
Until then, you can use your clothing and
accessories to convey your interests to others.
Like when I have bright pink hair, pretty
much everybody approaches me on the street.
Or I can just wear a geek shirt like this
one and you can come up, we can talk about
get repos or maybe after a few drinks, hard-core
forking action.
[Laughter]
Now, if you get really desperate, just give
away free shit. People love free shit. When
I was a kid in grade school, I used to bring
brags of candy to lunch during the holidays
and all my classmates became my best friends.
As a Googler, I basically did the same thing
except with free shirts and beer, which is
the adult equivalent. But sometimes it can
get exhausting to try and be approachable,
sometimes it can get expensive, and sometimes
it just doesn't work. So sometimes you just
simply have to admit you're shy, let people
know, and help them make it better for you.
With Google, you know, we all eat in these
big cafés, and, you know, my colleagues would
all wander off in different packs today and
I'd often wander into the café alone. I'd
look around at all the lunch tables, be way
too scared to sit at any of them, and bring
lunch back to my desk. I pretended to be all
absorbed in my work, but it was just a really
sad moment for me every day. And I was tired
of being sad every afternoon, so I eventually
told my colleagues about my lunchtime shyness.
From then on, he explicitly invited me to
lunch every day and made sure I had a seat
at his table, and so I no longer dreaded lunchtime.
So really, my actually hack in combating shyness
was to get a job that forced me to employ
all these work-arounds on a near daily base.
I basically got paid to face my fears for
four years and now I've got techniques to
last me a lifetime. I still get shy but I've
got the work-arounds.
Okay. So now that I've shared all my shyness
hacks with you, I want to hear about some
of yours, and I've now given you every possible
excuse to approach me and I want you to use
some of those excuses at the afterparty tonight.
I'd be in the corner, pink shirt -- pink share,
geek shirt. Thanks.
[Applause]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you very much, Pamela.
And now we've got another Googler. He still
works for the company, as you may know. We
all know him as the guy we go to with any
website questions, SEO questions, web spam
questions, but it turns out he does a whole
bunch of other stuff outside of his job, and
he's here to talk about his 30-day challenges.
Please welcome Matt Cutts.
[Applause]
>>Matt Cutts: All right. My name is Matt.
I work in search quality, but I'm going to
talk about something completely different.
A series of experiments I've been running
where I try new and different things for 30
days.
All I'm doing is saying, "Look, my life is
in a little bit of a rut, so I'm going to
follow in the footsteps of the great American
Philsopher, Morgan Spurlock." If you remember,
a few years ago, he recorded himself eating
McDonald's food for 30 days. Now he's a really
well-known filmmaker.
So anybody can do this. Anybody can try a
challenge.
You can do two major types of challenges.
You can either add something to your routine,
so walking 10,000 steps a day, or biking to
work, or if you're interested, you can also
subtract something from your daily routine.
Is Robert Scovel in the audience?
[Laughter]
He's not. Okay. I can make Robert Scovel jokes.
I once did a 30-day challenge where all I
did was try to get rid of Robert Scovel from
of my life? Out of my Twitter.
[Applause]
It's surprisingly easy.
I'm kidding. I love Robert Scovel.
The things that I learned when I did my 30-day
challenges. Number one, the time is much more
memorable. This was part of a challenge I
did to take a different picture every day,
and I remember exactly where I was and what
I was doing that day.
I also discovered that as I did more and more
30-day challenges, I couldn't help but start
to get in a little bit better shape, because
some of them were things like biking to work.
So this is me from a few years ago. I look
a little more chipmunk moon pie. But I started
out doing a 30-day challenge where I biked
to work, and I found after a few days, I actually
liked biking to work.
That was completely different for me.
And so I've lost about 40 pounds over the
last few years just from exercising.
[Applause]
Thank you.
I also discovered that I became a little more
adventurous, so last year I climbed Mt. Kilimanjaro,
the highest mountain in Africa. I would never
have been that adventurous. It helps a lot
with things like being shy if you're willing
to take on a new adventure on every 30 days.
Once you've done something like climb Mt.
Kilimanjaro, you think about what do you really
want to do. And I've always wanted to bring
a book. Every November, tens of thousands
of people try to write a book from scratch
in 30 days.
Now, it turns out it's not that hard. All
you have to do is write 1667 words a day for
an entire month.
[Laughter]
Here's the secret: All you have to do is make
sure that you write your words before you
go to sleep that night. You might be sleep-deprived,
but you will finish your book.
Now, a lot of people come up to me and they
say "Matt, can I read your book" or "Is it
the great next American novel"?
And the answer is: No! I wrote it in 30 days.
It's awful!
[Laughter]
But for the rest of my life, when I go to
a party, I don't have to introduce myself
as a computer scientist.
[Applause]
If I want to, I can say I'm a novelist.
So those are my 30-day challenges. But everybody's
going to be interested in something different,
right? The lady who cuts my hair decided she
wanted to go running with her dog every day.
And she discovered she was a morning person.
That would not have been my 30-day challenge,
but it worked really well for her. It might
be trying to go, instead of right-handed,
going left-handed for a month. It doesn't
matter. You pick what's right for you. Now,
I'm going to violate the cardinal rule and
be silent while you think of a 30-day challenge
you want. And here's a few ideas.
Got one? Okay.
Here's a few tips about how to do a 30-day
challenge.
My first one was giving up television for
30 days. I made it easy by watching all the
good season finales and then when the crappy
summer reality TV came on, that's when I did
my 30-day challenge, right?
[Laughter]
So make it easy on yourself.
I've learned that there's nothing wrong with
big huge challenges. In fact, they're a ton
of fun. But small ones are more likely to
stick. They're more likely to be sustainable.
It's also much easier to add a habit than
remove a habit. When I gave up sugar for 30
days, day 31 looked like this.
[Laughter]
My wife and I went to Krispy Kreme, the grocery
store, and every candy store, getting all
kinds of candy. It was fantastic. I couldn't
move for like a day.
[Laughter]
But the thing is, doing that with my wife
made me realize it's really helpful to have
a buddy. A buddy keeps you on track. So whether
it's writing a book or doing whatever, they're
going to keep you honest. They're going to
make sure that you're making good progress
on it.
Here's my final tip. You want to pick a challenge
that's kind of interesting.
You want the sort of reaction like this, right?
It's not just something small. You want to
be thinking about what's going to be a good
conversation starter? What's going to help
me strike up a good conversation with people?
So I want to close with a very simple question.
The next 30 days are going to pass, no matter
what. I guarantee it. So why not pick something
you have always wanted to try and give it
a shot for the next 30 days?
Thanks.
[Applause]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you very much, Matt.
Our next speaker was inspired by the tiger
mom's article that came out in the Wall Street
Journal a little while ago, and luckily she
happens to work as a data scientist at LinkedIn
and decided to see if there's any truth to
it. Please welcome up Monica Rogati.
[Applause]
>>Monica Rogati: Thanks, Brady.
Hi, everybody. I'm Monica Rogati. I'm a data
scientist at LinkedIn, and I'm here to talk
to you about finding stories in the data.
So a few months ago, there was this big controversy
about tiger moms and their parenting styles
and their outcomes. So I'm a data geek, so
my first instinct was, well, let's look at
the data.
But what kind of data do we have? Well, on
LinkedIn, we have a hundred million profiles,
and on those profiles, you can see things
like people's last name, their job titles,
and their region.
So basically, what you can do is you can look
at this data at the global level and sprinkle
in some machine learning, and then you can
have a pretty reasonable guess about where
each of those names originate from.
Right?
So then you can take what you've learned,
take it back to the United States, and look
at people's profiles.
And when you do that, you can look at what
job titles are overrepresented for a particular
region.
And going back to the tiger moms, well, so
as it turns out, the tiger cubs --
[Laughter]
-- do value scholastic achievement and statistics,
but they're not the only ones.
It turns out you can do this kind of analysis
for any type of region or any type of name
origin.
So we did this for eastern European names.
They look pretty similar. And you can contrast
them with western European names and they
optimize for slightly different metrics.
So what else is on LinkedIn? We have career
histories of a hundred million people, and
what you can do with that data at the aggregate
level, you can ask questions like: What's
-- where are people going? What's the hottest
industry right now? What are the fastest growing
job titles in a given year?
So if you do that, you can discover the tech
boom in 1999 and the corresponding bubble
burst when everybody went back to school.
[Laughter]
And you can look at today, right? And see
the rise in social media and data scientists,
of course. And you can see fads like gurus
going to ninjas going to rock stars.
So how do you find these data -- the stories
in the data?
Well, there are three simple ingredients.
Aggregate, normalize, and dig.
So aggregate across interesting dimensions,
normalize your raw data, and dig. Ask why.
Find the reason for the trend.
So when you aggregate, you can take some interesting
data like when people changed their job and
get a promotion, and you can aggregate it
by country and by month.
And then you can find interesting trends like
rediscovering India's fiscal year.
Then you have to normalize. That's crucial.
You have to find the denominator. There is
always a denominator. You have to look for
what's overrepresented, not just popular.
Here if we wanted to see a trend, we had to
look at relative change.
So then you have to dig. You have to ask why.
Why do you see that trend?
In this case, we looked at when people were
born, and we found our answer. It's the millennials.
They don't care what month of the year it
is. They want their promotion. So...
So let's see. Let's take another story. Top
overrepresented CEO names on LinkedIn.
Peter, Bob, Jack, you might look at those
names and say, "Well, those are just popular
baby names 50 years ago," and you're right.
But that's not the whole story.
To find the real story, you have to dig.
And look at the length of the names. If you
look at that, you'll find quintessential sales
guys like Chip, Todd and Trey, right?
The CEO distribution is not as skewed. Jack,
Fred, Bill.
But you can -- they still want you to be a
friend, so they use nicknames.
So the media allows this stuff, so the question
is: How do you communicate the data stories?
The infographics are awesome, but the story
itself has to be compelling. It has to be
interesting, it has to be accessible, and
it has to be relatable.
Howard Stern covered this, because one of
the CEO names was Howard.
So obviously there's lots of interesting data
stories, and we all love data and we want
more of it. I'm no different. That's my license
plate.
[Laughter]
But the data isn't enough. What you want is
you want to dig and find the story in the
data.
So if you like finding stories in data and
love big data, let's chat. Thanks.
[Applause]
>>Brady Forrest: Thank you very much, Monica.
Our next speaker is also going to talk about
data, except it's about inane data. Please
welcome NYU's Patrick Davison.
[ Applause ]
>>Patrick Davison: So it was just before Thanksgiving
of 2009 when my roommate, Mike Rugnetta, came
into the living room to tell me that the music
video for Avril Lavigne's "Girlfriend" had
been deleted from YouTube. He and I knew this,
because Avril Lavigne's "Girlfriend" was part
of what we call the Golden Four, which was,
to our knowledge, the first four YouTube videos
to have over 100 million views. Now Mike Rugnetta
and I are a little different than a lot of
people because we see the YouTube comments
as having a distinct cultural value.
[ Laughter ]
So we've been looking at these for the last
two years, and we've come up with three challenges
in doing so. And that's what I want talk about
today.
Challenge number one is that YouTube comments
are kind of hard to hold on to. In the case
of Avril Lavigne's "Girlfriend" if the video
disappears, so do all of your comments. And,
even if the video doesn't disappear, it turns
out that Google and YouTube's API only allows
you to grab the last 1,000 comments which
I talked to the API guys a couple hours ago.
And they said they're going to undo that by
the end of the month. So maybe challenge one
is gone, so never mind. Also spoiler alert:
If you're, like, really worried about the
Avril Lavigne situation, you should know that
it just got taken down so they could convert
it to Vivo. So it's back up, and you might
find it if you Google or YouTuble that. That's
fine.
Challenge 2 is global warming. As the world
gets warmer, YouTube comments tend to stick
together -- I don't know anything about global
warming. This is not true at all. There's
a very smart historian named Paul N. Edwards
who has studied the history of climate science.
And he said something like this: Virtually
everything we know about anything complex
depends on computer models. Right? When you
have a system of data that's as complex as
the world's climate system, you need computers
to help out. Right?
He puts it shortly this way: No one lives
in a global climate. Right? There's no single
person in the entire world who has experienced
the weather of the entire world. That's where
the computers come in. It's funny he says
this. Because there's another theorist named
Wendy Chun. She doesn't write about the weather,
but she does say is a global picture of new
media possible?
So, if we believe that one person can't experience
all the weather of the world, I think it's
easy to believe that one person can't experience
all of the YouTube comments in the world.
Right?
I mean, it only takes a little while looking
at this list of all of the user names of everyone
who's commented on Avril Lavigne's "Girlfriend"
to realize how complex this system actually
is. And that's before you realize this is
just for one video and it's just the people
who commented in the last three weeks. If
you take every comment for every video from
all of time, that system seems to be just
about as complex as maybe the world's weather
system.
So what do we do with this.
Right?
Well, there's some differences. Climate data
is definitely scientific data, right?
It's things that you can count and measure.
But YouTube comments tend to be made of cultural
data. It's things like language and sentiment
that are a little bit harder to pour into
a database. Right?
I mean, if you think about Shakespeare, for
instance, what do we do with Shakespeare?
We read Shakespeare. We don't use it to make
a tag cloud.
[ Laughter ]
If we do, it feels kind of wrong, kind of
dirty like you're not doing it justice. But,
you know, YouTube is not Shakespeare.
[ Applause ]
But, I mean, if you spend enough time looking
at YouTube comments, which I do, you'll find
what I would describe as hidden poetry.
[ Laughter ]
So we've got the first two challenges. Where
does this leave us?
We've got access and the need for models that
give us a giant system of cultural data that's
a little hard to get at. What's our third
challenge?
Well, our third challenge makes the first
two harder. So me and my roommate, Mike, we
can sit at home and come up with grassroots
methods and show people lists and analyses
that we've made sitting in our bedroom. But
the reaction is always going to be the same.
Whoever we show this to is, "Okay, great.
YouTube comments are worthless. Why did you
do this?"
Maybe my dad summed it up best last week when
he tweeted at me saying, "YouTube comments
are more like verbal vomit."
This third challenge is the attitude that
people have toward towards this kind of data.
So, if there's one lesson I can leave you
with that global warming has taught me about
YouTube comments it's this: Climate scientists,
they study the weather. Whether it's bad weather
or good weather, it's data to them. And, if
we want to be serious about being cultural
scientists, then we need to treat that data
the same way. YouTube comments might be the
shitty snowstorm of the Internet, but we still
need to pay attention. Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>>Brady Forrest: If you enjoyed Patrick's
talk, he's also a writer and on "No, you're
mean," which we all love. And then he also
did my all-time favorite Ignite talk called
"Plight of the Digital Chickens," which you
can find on YouTuble.
Our last speaker is also an ex-Googler. And
he's here to talk about open versus closed.
Please welcome Kevin Marks.
>>Kevin Marks: Thank you. So I spent a lot
of time on the Gilmore Gang talking about
openness versus closedness with the guys there.
And I wonder what got me there, so I thought
I'd look back through my history and work
out how I came to these conclusions in the
first place. That isn't actually my history.
It's my country's history. Back in feudal
times, land was the key to everything. If
you owned land, that gave you control. That
gave you power over other people. You could
force them to do things. Land ownership is
key. And you have to compete over it. If I
have it, you can't have it. And this spread
into culture, too.
When professions are were set up, they were
granted royal charters. They were, basically,
given monopoly over their profession to decide
who could and couldn't do it. That was the
assumption that came from land. It moved along
that way. And it fed into copyrights and patents,
too. In effect, the copyright rules are medieval
monopolies granted by the state that says
you can do this and nobody else can. It's
like the same charter they granted the British
East India Company that said only you get
to go to India. Excluding others was what
they thought was the key to extracting value.
If you look patents like this one for an eraser
that goes over your finger, the whole point
is that's a brilliant idea. Nobody else can
possibly do this without paying. But, actually,
we know exclusivity is the enemy of culture.
I rehearsed the argument. Lessig has been
doing this for 10 years. Go read some of his
books. Watch his presentations. The whole
point is culture is built on other people's
thoughts and ideas, too. That's how we connect
together. That's how we get culture in the
first place. And keeping this stuff locked
up is really fragile. If you stop people copying
stuff and sharing stuff, you can lose it.
The Internet archive is trying to preserve
the Internet from these kind of losses. And
they said, if you keep stuff secret, it would
cost you thousands of dollars to preserve
it forever. If you share it in public, it's
a different story.
Back to my personal story. I joined the BBC
in 1998. One of the first places I worked
was the BBC archive where they had racks and
racks of videotapes and films on the walls.
The thing is they weren't copying the videotapes.
The oxide fell off the tapes, and they lost
10 years' worth of programming because they
weren't doing rolling backups. What they had
to do was go around to the people who had
been illegally copying the tapes onto private
stuff and get them back so we could see old
Dr. Who's. There's a project called LOCKSS,
Lots of Copies Keeps Stuff at Stanford, which
is trying to do this digitally. I recommend
looking at that, the principles of that. The
point is, if you want culture to persist,
you have to have lots of copies of it.
So I worked on a CD-ROM title called 3D Atlas.
If you bought a Mac around that time, you
probably got it bundled. We sold two million
copies. It was pretty successful. Things were
great. We thought great. We'll burn lots of
CD-ROMs. Couple years later CD-ROMs weren't
so hot. There was an Internet thing. And we
had a brilliant idea. What if, instead of
making 3D rendered movies, we chopped up pictures
of the earth into little tiles and stored
those all on a server and fetched them over
the Internet and stuck them together with
a 3D card?
We built this in '97. But the people who owned
the company decided they didn't want to do
this. They'd rather shut the company down.
So I had to go and find another job. But I
couldn't take the idea with me. So when Keyhole
and Google Earth came out a few years later,
oh, yeah, somebody did it too. Sort of personally
painful.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm glad somebody else did it.
So in 1987, Apple produced this thing called
HyperCard. Anybody remember this thing?
Some of you are as old as me. It let you do
this web-like thing of making little textual
things that linked together. In '91 they had
a thing called QuickTime. It played movies
over the net. It was powerful. I worked there
at Apple. I joined in 1997. And they were
going to join them together. Combine HyperCard
with QuickTime. It was a beautiful thing.
But Steve Jobs killed it. And he's proud of
that. He boasted about it last year. He said,
"We were right to kill HyperCard. It was crap,"
just like Flash is.
I paraphrase slightly.
So the problem with closed software is it's
fragile. It takes one bad decision to kill
it. And all those people who built businesses
on HyperCard were no longer able to do anything.
They were waiting for the release from Apple.
The release was there. They built it for OS10.
It's still sitting in the box. But it's been
shut off.
So open source is great for engineers. Because
engineers, even if they leave the company,
can take their source with them. If I had
open sourced the 3D Atlas thing in '96, I
could have carried on working after they shut
the company down. That would have been great
for me. But it's also great for the companies.
Because be the companies can still have access
to the engineers after they've left.
This is a long quote from Ian Hickson. But,
basically, he's saying the point of the HTML5
project is to preserve culture, to make sure
we can still read the web in the future by
documenting how the stuff works. The real
value of the openness stuff is summed up by
Doc Searls. No one owns. Everyone can use
it. Anyone can improve it. The point is you
gain more control by giving up ownership because
you're giving everyone else control, too.
[ Applause ]
>>Brady Forrest: All right. Thank you all
for coming out. The videos will be up on igniteshow.com
and up on YouTube later.
Now, in case you've never been to an Ignite
before or there isn't one locally, Ignite
is all over the world. It's in 200 cities.
And all you need is a projector, beer, and
gullible people. So, if you want to start
an Ignite -- there's hundreds more of these
logos where these came from -- just contact
me or go to igniteshow.com/howto or start
your own.
I'd like to thank Google for having us back
for the third year.
And thanks to all of our speakers.
Can you give them a round of applause?
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.